here we are
guess i just gotta wait
v got a job for you my client had a
shitload of beta acids stolen
what's beta acid you might wonder [ __ ]
if i know
but it's worth a lot and our client
wants it back
that's where you come in iron at the
ready
more info attached
[Music]
huh bill jablonski
did okada give you the details
my info is i'm supposed to off someone
no not just anyone joshua stevenson a
[ __ ] murderer
i'll tell you more inside get in you're
driving
they're supposed to pass down this
street we just sit tight till they show
up
and follow him i want to see the light
in that motherfucker's eyes go out
whoa why so he can smell his own fear
before he dies
one and dead why exactly that's not your
concern
rather know what i'm getting into
stevenson murdered my wife they
convicted him put him on death row
but the slime bag found a get out of
jail free card
over my dead [ __ ] body
nothing to do but wait then what's your
name
unimportant unimportant
the same thing they told me when i
wanted to know his real name
the dirtbag who killed her i
there they are step on it
stay on him don't let him get away
what
[Applause]
[Music]
we can't lose him
[ __ ]
stop the damn car [ __ ] break i said
break this is it
let's go
stay close i'm gonna blow the
[ __ ] to bits myself
[Music]
i'm gonna do it i'm gonna [ __ ] kill
him
ncpd stop right there
lieutenant vasquez ncpd stop right there
you're protecting a murderer drop it all
i shoot
wait no stop stop the killing
they're here to kill you it's not their
fault
shoot the guy and our deal is dead
vasquez
shoot right let's just all shoot holes
at each other
out loud [ __ ] we can't leave him here
media vultures will be here any minute
the [ __ ] are you doing
stop ncpd
and stay where you are and get that
goddamn semi out of here
we take him with us what
it was only a matter of time
i can explain just thanks i owe you
don't go no patrol car
and stay off the frequencies can't have
this coming back
it's okay you don't need to tell me
my name is joshua stevenson [ __ ] mess
dropping you a kid associate listen what
was his name
we're clear to go boys from the precinct
will mop up here
already i deed him bill jablonski
teach us to number our days that we may
gain a heart of wisdom
wait a second you're v i heard of you
can't say the same about you we can't
take him
out of the question he's way too big a
threat
well i want to give him a job ah
christ on a stick finally something that
isn't a complete snore fest
could binge watch this all day if i had
some popcorn
gonna tell me what it is you want from
me well this one time rachel is right
we can't stay here come with us
you'll find out all you need to know
gotta object
strongly noted but you don't have a vote
here
that's it got no [ __ ] idea what this
is about
but if you don't go with them i'm never
talking to you again
all right i'll go with you
remove it we're running late
have you ever experienced anything that
changed the meaning of existence
changed your life
[ __ ] the hell possessed me to get in
12 years ago i was sentenced to prison
for
armed robbery and other sins
i shot and killed several people in cold
blood
and it didn't mean anything to me at the
time but behind bars you get
all the time in the world to think
and i thought to correct the errors
of my ways
spelling mistakes you can correct but
murder is murder
you can make amends to the families you
can lead others away from the path of
darkness
spill already what do you want from me
stay with me for the day and i'll pay
you what you were promised to kill me
uh excuse me with what money
not mine the studios and the studio
will petty
you know still got that contract to kill
you
what's to stop me from fulfilling me
one strange twitch i kill you hey
there's no reason to upset vasquez
your fixer will get what they want i'll
make sure of it
how you figured that trust me
everyone will be satisfied i guarantee
you
just till the end of the day till the
end of the day
i sense anything going wrong i'm out
no one will force you to stay
we're almost at gloria lmrs
give me a moment i need to prepare
[Music]
baskets keep an eye on them i'm gonna
stay in the car
keep it short we're on a tight schedule